I'm on it while Kevin we're here in the
UAE and the planet it will block here
the rollingwood Ross Mojave and some of
the FC players and we're in the mission
it's a beautiful architecture here comes
our we're gonna say to the camera you
are beautiful architecture that's right
I mean they speak the truth yeah say
hello how you find that how you found
the numeration well you know the Dean
you have see flights ah I find love love
for for us in this community
[Laughter]
is very different than America
much more intense polar bears you don't
have polar bears you can say in America
you guys wrestle grizzly bears
but you guys don't make it to the
Olympic you don't do in the Olympics
that would be you
Salam alaikum how's it gonna hear right
right okay so here's my variation of a
bassoon yes
when you were born
we told you your name is Polynesia
we tell you what your name is the its
condition it could have been something
else yeah
when you were born you you you learn
about the dunya you learn about the
dirty educate you you see something cold
for the first time you see something
something big something small something
rough something smooth you're learning
all about the duniya for the census
however there was a point in time when
you were alive where he didn't know
about your identity and you had it
interacted with the dunya
there was a point in time where there
was no identity no self no ego
and there was no interaction with the
dunya at all even when you were just
just born there's a minimal interaction
with the dunya that you're not even
aware of this state of there's no name
there's no artificial experience there's
no sensory experience with the dunya
this is a state of Lillehammer Allah why
because all there is is an awareness
within this awareness everything is
contained your whole existence is
contained your identity the dunya that's
why for instance when we ask materialist
philosophers to show us
materialism something outside this
self-awareness they cannot logically
speaking they cannot they always start
with the premise that okay your brain is
material therefore if you puncture the
brain the consciousness is gone when
they started with the brain is material
I'm asking him to prove materialism and
his premise starts with having to accept
materialism
but put that aside for now the argument
of materialism dualism and I feel as a
subsistence put that ass economic there
was a state of a human being where there
is nothing but awareness this is the
state of Lillehammer law and this is why
I said he says the Prophet told us were
all born Muslim and then your parents
change you to something else to
condition you to make you believe a
certain person is God or not I have to
condition you but what is your fitna
what was your natural religion or were
you born in
there's no way out of here sorry sir
there's no way he thought I was coming
in you guys saw that this man was will
about MMA and he doesn't think this is a
stereotype with coaches and fires any
what he's trying to say times are you
were talking about justified true belief
yes
even justified true belief doesn't even
eliminate all doubt now we have to
remember we're not talking about
pragmatism here knowledge that's useful
for putting a roof over your head we're
talking about absolute truth we're
talking about are you curious about some
people are not interested in truth some
people are just interested about what
put some food in their belly and a
shelter over their head after that they
don't want to talk anymore so this topic
doesn't interest you change the channel
because people you know they're always
asking me okay well how do you make
money with this idea this is not about
making money it's not about pragmatism
sometimes people say I love truth I love
truth you know people can't handle the
truth we believe in this truth truth I
was talking about you
what do you mean by true with oftentimes
what they mean is pragmatism what they
love is the dunya what they love is hey
do these methods and belief bring me
resources they work did it work or not
exactly but because something works and
we can find many examples of things
people believe things that worked but
there actually weren't true now they've
been debug like for instance we used to
believe bloodletting works
Galen we believe bloodletting is he let
blood out he would help you serve I was
actually untrue completely false but my
point being is this they believed it was
true so they they believed it was true
they thought I was working so they
called it the truth to them he was a
rosary source
even things that actually really do work
in the world later on find out the
reason why they worked is completely
different than the original reason why
so what are we talking about here
there if you're truly a lover of
knowledge you're gonna crank up the dial
of skepticism now today the lowest level
of skepticism we can accept is the
scientific method
you have a hypotheses we have to test it
has to be predictive as to be
falsifiable etc but David Hume has le
Emanuel cap this was not enough for them
they went even further they wanted to
know what's that puts the truth in the
ultimate sense so if you were reading
their writings you're talking about a
whole different subject here
so this is this is what we're talking
about now what is actually true cannot
be denied
there's no new evidence in the future
there's no new argument that's gonna
come it's bulletproof has Ally bonded
down to this point of awareness the
Canadian guy come into to the Y to look
at to take photos take falls of war snow
yeah artificial artificial actually
rules it's artificial snow this is what
they do in the bike
so for us the Hubble you have a little
cheap mill they give the recipe to the
Cheesecake Factory
[Laughter]
sorry cool so go and tell us what your
son said so we do it on a regular basis
we go to the gym almost every single day
so one day my son my my little son
it's actually 705 he's like papa he
interrupted the sign yeah everything
happened because of something else he's
telling me no past events led to this
event then he told me and your son is
like 8 years old there so that's what
happens when you have a philosopher as a
father and everything's gonna be ok
I can tell you it has this innate sense
that everything's okay everything is
okay everything's gonna be okay I was
really amazed because you know what they
haven't had the time to be influenced by
their environment as much as us or
indoctrinated or school than a school of
thought these are just as natural five
circles
it's incredible so that's the importance
of reflection silence silence long
period of time some people cannot stand
silence the reason why people cannot use
with sense science is because I believe
a deep-seated fear of death all your
anxieties come from your fear of death
the last of me your fear of death you're
constantly distracting yourself with
coffee a movie if you see if I sit you
in a room with no entertainment no
danger no danger ergo entertainment some
people will become mad
you're gonna live your own personal
health and that move and some people are
gonna fight piece
it depends how your mind is
but people were constantly trying to
distract themselves they're running from
a particular health
quiet quiet in silence when being with
yourself ISM and sufferable insufferable
you can't stand yourself there are some
people they cannot have peace some
people they call it intrinsic they can't
stop talking and making noises it's a
non-stop concert those people my opinion
are uncomfortable with themselves and
the idea of death because the second the
second things are calm there's not
having deep thoughts when you have deep
thoughts one philosopher put it that
said don't think we don't do philosophy
if you don't want to see yourself look
at yourself because you're going to see
some type of ugliness and you're gonna
have to deal with it that's why some
people are so preoccupied they never
want to have any kind of experience
because they cannot stand themselves
this is the truth if you look at all the
stages the prophets the wise man they
all have times of seclusion the Prophet
indicator Jesus's wilderness Buddha
under the tree there was always a period
of time of apology a stigma Tesla Isaac
Newton even even when we receive our
culture there was a time word
Sullivan when Isaac Newton wrote the
three laws of motion he was hiding from
the plane when Descartes wrote his
meditations he spent he was isolated
I spent alone in the cabinet they were
all running from the plague disease yeah
yeah you said you if you went away for
ten years solitude is a very special
case good leg of lamb before this guy
was a vegetarian it's took about leg of
lamb poutine how about you because I'm
an ego this you got a translator here
it looks better at this country
[Music]
got me through state can live and
it's what you take when you take
ourselves to the party
and then we painted my god you're the
authority get on the bike
that was the hole
so there's ago the communities enough
I can say for the same thing and then I
already is so just for the benefits of
the tape so when we're talking about the
Kartika canonicity which is that the
fries come together and they want to
canonize the Bible they want an
authoritative text the main criteria is
that is going to be the revelation of
the text with a can on the Bible if
agrees with our teachings but the whole
point of pattern of canonization is that
they had to find a text to you to derive
evidence for the beliefs values and etc
so you see the second argument to say
what's authentic naturally does apply
sometimes oh but the Holy Spirit was
working the hemisphere was working they
see the Holy Spirit was working and I
have another argument with me where'd
you get the idea the cause of the Holy
Spirit from the Bible they get back into
that nice angle
[Music]
this is the end of our to Abu Dhabi
that's some strategic means in this
important things for foreign-born people
so this is it had some really
interesting composition for us how did
you know
one student
very simple insight on the parenting
class again yeah yeah it's good but not
and not not to be fair not many people
can specialize in to areas like that no
definite
I always guys